well it's a staggering increase that
affects thousands
unemployment claims continue to climb
across our state with initial claims up
36
compared to last week the second biggest
jump in claim activity since mid-october
now the number of initial claims filed
for pandemic unemployment assistance
pua was up more than 600 percent
no surprise jeter says this is raising
some red flags the i-team's david charns
is live
in the newsroom with what we know and
what people are saying
about it david hey kirsten this spike
sticking out for sure
more than 61 000 initial pua claims
filed last week that's
a 635 yes 635 percent
jump from the week before today we
talked to three people in our area
looking for help
having trouble getting it and they're
just now furious
not only infuriated but i'm out of often
then you just call and call and call
it's mostly
just like worrisome just not having any
stability
nine months into this pandemic and out
of work
we've heard it over and over the idea is
that you don't go broke
and you help you out until you get back
on your feet problems getting in touch
with dieter
and getting help paying the bills robert
phillips is one of those people
he's been waiting months just to hear if
he's eligible
all i expect is an answer to routine
correspondence i have
filed for unemployment july the 19th
a reasonable an average person on the
street would expect within a month
maybe six weeks using post office rules
you know
things take time but not going on five
months without a dime on something
that's really critical
then news friday that first time
claimants for pua benefits
those for contract and gig workers
jumped more than
600 percent from the week before this
graph showing that huge spike
in its raising red flags it's
frustrating because
you are left with that with all of these
questions that
you need answered jamie reiser is a
substitute teacher and says dieter
asked her to send money back but she
says she can't get in touch with them
and she's frustrated there are going to
be people that scam the system and
hopefully they're the ones that get
caught and have to pay the money back
not the people that
need it caitlyn ducette lost her job in
april
she too has yet to hear anything but
it's just
very frustrating especially to see like
so many people getting
their benefits and they're getting you
know the pandemic assistance and they're
getting the extra weeks
and it's like i haven't even you know
got a phone call
back in a statement a deter spokeswoman
says this marked increase
is questionable given the underlying
economic conditions
now we did talk to several other people
today who said it's not
fair that those cheating the system are
getting money while they're still
waiting to even hear if
they can get benefits the item did reach
out to dieter to get more information on
all this today
and we did not hear back live in the
newsroom i'm david charns 8 news now